[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's time what is up what is good how
you living how you feeling how you doing
we
are 42 hours excuse me 42 days
and seven hours away from the nfl draft
and the guy to my left connor rogers is
here to let me pick his brain
to get ready for that three day event
connor we are going to be cramming for
draft weekend
on br app gridiron twitter and br
youtube
and of course the theme music here on
the left go show if you're listening
after the fact brought to you by rod
simba
the regulators and rodrigo the theme
this week connor
is most electric prospects before we get
into everything how electric
is this draft class and i'll keep doing
the intro after you talk
i mean it's right up there lefko it's
the speed demon show today you get the
guys that can fly
it's not necessarily these workout
wonders we're gonna do that another week
but it's really the players that
when the ball is in their hands look out
they can go the distance at any point
and we have a lot to go through today
i'm really excited for this one i have
uh the app up right now
i am watching live i am making sure i
get all of your comments i will be
reading them throughout the show
also you can submit your questions as
videos in the nfl draft community
and we will play them live on the show
we are gonna play three on the show
today
if your video is played we will be
sending you a br gridiron hoodie
so yeah you get some face time and
you're gonna get a hoodie and you can
ask us
anything it does not have to just stick
to the show's theme which of course
today as we mentioned is the most
electric prospects uh no combine this
year
and that's usually where they run the 40
and rich eisen freaks out about how fast
they run
and we're watching all the shuttle
drills and stuff how much stock you
putting into these pro day times these
individual workout times how do you
handle that as an individual evaluator
well that's all we got left go so we're
gonna have to use it in some way shape
or form and i look at it generally how
you rule out pro days because we see
year after year guys go
not going to run at the combine i'm
going to save it for my pro day
and when that happens you often add a
10th of a second which can be a big
difference we've seen
astronomical differences in numbers when
guys run
both it's interesting when they do do
both so i think when you look at it
you got to trust there are scouts on the
ground doing the classic hand
timing and everybody's a little bit
different so you're going to get a range
of times that come out on social media
and you go somewhere in the middle and
as always let go
combine pro day private facility workout
i don't care where it is spring recorded
time when they're still at college
does the play speed match the track
speed that's what matters most
uh amazing comment already from ic wood
watching while my fiance is in labor
don't tell her
we're not telling anybody but i'll tell
you what your fiance must be
electric if she's performing under this
kind of circumstance
uh i had you make a list of 10. i wanted
connor rogers 10 most electric prospects
let's throw that up now and see
who made the list uh got a number of
running backs
five wide receivers three corners
etienne and naji harris at running back
three corners farley stokes and newsome
and five wide receivers jalen waddle
tutu atwell
jalen darden anthony schwartz and duane
eskridge connor i did see some video
of eric stokes this week was that the
most impressive electric prospect
performing in the last week or two yeah
i mean listen this is a player that had
a few pick sixes in his career at
georgia so it's no surprise that he can
fly but
lefko this is somebody that we're
looking at a real possible four to eight
kind of 40 yard dash so the straight
line speed for someone that is
over six feet tall and is not exactly
light
it's crazy it's special and you go back
to that list you look at someone like
travis etienne
he's a running back that when the ball
is in his hands he can go the distance
any time he touches it caleb farley of
course didn't play this year but one of
the better athletes we've seen at the
position in the last couple years
and then that receivers we're going to
talk about all of them
it's a special group they can all fly
you have somebody that possibly could
have been an olympian
if he decided to go that route anthony
schwartz who had his pro day today
and ran in the four twos we'll see what
official time we actually get there
jalen darden a north texas guy so a
small school guy that you should be
familiar with
these guys can all fly the straight line
speed is there
and we've seen it all on the field
already where we feel pretty good about
it even for the ones that didn't run yet
conor a lot of people are upset you
didn't mention cadarius tony what do you
think about that
well i think with kadarius tony can he
make you miss can he run through you
absolutely but is he straight line speed
no he's not he's not somebody that i see
running
uh in the four threes even a 4-4 i think
cadarius tony will honestly run in the
four fives and if i'm wrong i'll get on
this show
and give a big apology but you're
talking about more
lateral agility with kedarius tony
rather than straight line
home run type of speed uh
garrett greenlee sorry for missing the
first few minutes it's okay welcome back
uh so before we get into all the
prospect the most electric prospects
i do want to just talk a little bit
about free agency we have seen some
crazy movements and because free agency
happens before the draft
a lot of these holes are being filled
whether it's towards the top of the
draft
or moving on uh we do have an app
comment and a question about one of the
teams i believe they're picking around
19th
the washington football team uh windmill
888 what position should washington
target in the first round they're one of
their biggest off signings was curtis
samuel
and ryan fitzpatrick connor what do you
think about washington
well i'm glad that we got a question
about washington because i tweeted out
this has been my favorite free agency so
far and you want to talk about electric
players they also got
curtis samuel left ghost and now the
door is wide open for them
where they can win right now obviously
they won the division last year as bad
as it was but they can actually take
that and run with it i think fitzpatrick
will be an upgraded quarterback for them
great cornerback and william jackson is
in addition curtis samuel so when you
look at what they could do in the draft
they can beef up the offensive line i
like christian darisol if they stay
tight at 19. i think there's nothing
wrong with that
but if they opt to move up and really
get a package together for
a quarterback kind of like a tua
fitzpatrick dynamic we saw in miami last
year
if they want to do that you have the
potential to grab mac jones you have
potential to grab trey lance they're
going to be out of the conversation for
trevor lawrence
zach wilson and probably even justin
fields that would be a colossal jump
but for washington the fact that they've
opened the door of what they can do
i like staying put and getting that
offensive tackle
and really having a great offensive line
for is what's an ascending offense
maybe the most active free agency
undoubtedly has been the patriots they
go and get two tight ends johnny smith
and
hunter henry uh they had nelson aguilar
they had jalen mills
they trade for trent brown kendrick born
they get from the 49ers they resign cam
newton
this list is extensive and i don't want
to miss old hank anderson
added to the d-line but what's
interesting also is the contractor
paying at cam newton
is again pretty low do you expect them
to make any moves
uh and and what do you think their
approach to the draft is going to be
i think it should be for a quarterback
honestly and when you look at the money
and the fact that cam newton now has the
full year in the system and a lot of
things are on his
side but without the incentives left go
he is being paid back up quarterback
money where
they're not necessarily committing to
him and if you take this guy
trey lance you're gonna have to go up
from 15 to get him which they easily can
do
you can run the same system i mean look
at what he can do in the open field as a
big-bodied
hard-nosed runner we know he has the arm
strength to really hit any throw
on the field do people think he's gonna
be ready to go day one
probably not but that's okay because you
got cam newton back
and now sure they drafted two tight ends
in the third round last year
they're obviously not waiting around for
anyone to develop bill belichick sitting
there and going
i'm not getting any younger let's get
two guys that can give us a little bit
of what we had in 2010 at the tight end
position
beef up our wide receivers get a little
bit more reliable there
now you're not going into the trap with
900 needs anymore left go where you can
use your other picks and put a package
together
get your quarterback in the future while
also having a win now roster
uh that should be interesting be our
gridiron throwing in there should the
patch draft a quarterback
you never know with bill you really
never know let's stay in your division
i think it's time last week we kind of
did is it guaranteed that the
jacksonville jaguars are going to take
trevor lawrence
uh as a jets fan i know juju smith
schuster is
at the facility and they're talking to
people right now they've gone out there
and
signed corey davis which was a nice
signing um
and uh i'm curious though what is a
here are some other signings the carl
lost someone i know you love you
you but you guys have been looking for a
pass rusher since john abraham let's be
honest
that's exactly right lefko so when you
look at what the jets did have they done
a ton so far
not necessarily but they've made impact
signings we know corey davis is somebody
that can easily go out there and be a
highly productive starter in this
offense coming from tennessee it's the
same exact passing concepts that the
jets are going to run
with mike leflore where now you're
starting to knock some needs off the
board you don't necessarily
need a wide receiver in the first or
second round anymore you absolutely need
offensive line
we feel pretty confident they're going
to trade sam darnold and probably draft
a guy like zach wilson number two
overall and even if they don't they
would take a quarterback
like justin fields instead so their
options are on the table at number two
overall
so for the jets now you got a pass
rusher you needed at least one you
probably need another one for robert
sala you need some help at corner you
need some help on the offensive line but
it's a really good
start where they're trying not to make
the same mistake they made with sam
darnold and now they want to do it with
a different quarterback in my eyes
here's a dream draft for the new york
jets with their first three picks
because they got
three picks in the top 35 here you get
zach wilson we talked last week how much
of a fit he is in this offense at number
two
but you missed on joe tooney you weren't
that active on corey linsley
you need help on the interior offensive
line that's why i look at elijah vera
tucker who played left tackle
at a high level for usc last year and
he's played left guard at a high level
so he can come in
and start right next to makai bechten
you have to absolutely
love that left side of your offensive
line and then you get to the top of the
second round and you look at somebody
like greg newsom who really really fits
the scheme
timed as a sub 4-4 player he ran 4-3-7
and it's real left go you look at what
he can do as an off coverage cornerback
that's going to be perfect in this cover
3 scheme that robert sala wants to run
so
did they knock out all their needs in
free agency no that's impossible they're
not going to be able to do that with the
holes on the roster but with that dream
draft
i would say the robert sala error would
be off to a really good start for the
new york jets
i always want to follow that up with
what would be the nightmare draft
uh so let me ask you real i just want to
know it's just one question
who could they take at number two that
would leave you a little upset
let's just be honest right now i mean
honestly anyone that's not a quarterback
because that means they're moving
forward with sam darnold and i think
that's not good enough for the new york
jets sure he hasn't had the help
but you see it on tape for three years
even when things have been right
it hasn't worked for sam darnold you got
to get a fresh start
you're not going to take another
offensive line and still question at
your quarterback position you're not
going to draft a wide receiver at number
two overall
i love kyle pitts you're not taking a
tight end at number two
once again it just doesn't make any
sense in terms of
in terms of building your football team
we are now going to go to a video
question our first one of the day and
whoever asks it is going to get a br
gridiron hoodie
and it is coming in from pat chamberlain
so take it away pat
connor let go this just hit me and i had
to post it
i know the jets need a quarterback but
they've got darnold whether he's your
quarterback or not
but imagine if they went with sewell at
two
paired him up with mackay becton you
would have millions
and millions of pancakes
let me hear what you guys have to say
about that thanks guys
pretty good and it is friends
and millions it was pretty good i mean
that's that's our guy actually andrew
harbaugh
a former uh big time stick to football
listener
so we'll get to pat chamberlain in a
little bit that's from andrew harbaugh
listen sewell is exciting he's my number
two player overall
it would be a phenomenal offensive line
but it's
it's not 1980 anymore adam lefko you're
not gonna run the ball
a million times a game and never throw
it's just in this guerra you have to
have a guy back there that can really
take over as a passer
and i think for the jets they've locked
themselves into a spot at number two
where
they need to get their guy in the future
align your gm
your head coach and your quarterback all
together
i really like the chat right now in the
nfl draft stream because they all know
who andrew harbaugh is
and they all know who pat chamberlain is
and so i apologize to the legend that is
andrew harbaugh the beard looks great by
the way my friend
uh we do have an app comment a little
off the wall here from the breadman 10
asking connor if you had to choose three
prospects to take out for lunch
who would they be and this could be a
salad
this could be a pizza hut lunch buffet
it could be any type of lunch i see
you're looking at your draft board right
now
what is going into the qualifications of
lunch with connor
i mean basically who the biggest guys
are i just want to see how much they can
eat we're going to have a buffet over
here right so i think when you look at
it like that
i'll start with ben cleveland from
georgia he looks like the mountain left
go
he he's gonna play guard at the nfl
level uh he's a pretty good athlete for
his size so i think ben cleveland is
somebody that
you're gonna sit down and you're
probably gonna be eating for about six
hours which
i know it might not look like it but
that's my kind of guy i'll sit at the
dinner table for a long time
let's get to somebody else a little bit
more fun i i would want to sit down
and probably talk to jalen phillips
would be a guy from miami just to get to
know what his career has been like i
talked about him as one of the more
polarizing guys in this draft
starts his career at ucla as a recruit
he's kind of
you know received as the next miles
garrett right the expectations are
ridiculous
but he transferred and had to medically
retire because things got so bad with
concussions and a lot of different
injuries at one point
took a year off from football and really
all figured it out at miami is i don't
want to call him a one-year wonder but
that's essentially what he was at miami
where
i'd want to sit down and go man when did
the light come on for you
what changed so i think you look and i
think a lot of scouts are wondering the
same thing so
a fun one with ben cleveland because we
just want to sit knee but the scout side
of me wants to sit down and talk to
jalen phillips and just ask him
what this other you know what this
season has been like and then i think
the third one for me
would be justin fields because i just
want to ask
what is it like being doubted all the
time for what reasons are are you
do are there so many doubters about you
right we've heard he came in as the 1b
to trevor lawrence's 1a in that
recruiting class left go and when you
look at it trevor lawrence had his great
moments in college
but justin fields it started a little
later because he was a transfer but when
you look at it he's had phenomenal
moments as well so i'd want to sit down
and go
are you bothered that you're overlooked
what's going on with you so i think i
love justin fields and i just think it
would be a really interesting
conversation
he seems like a guy that's unfazed
though by all of that
garrett greenlee saying connor taking
the peter luger steakhouse on that
company card
pat chamberlain saying pizza lunch
buffet is undefeated and it is because
if you haven't had
that apple dessert pizza then you
probably missed out zach wilson also
looks like he dips his pizza in ranch
let's go to pat chamberlain now let's
get his video comment in because he has
been waiting patiently
let's hear what pat asked hey connor and
lefko
i'm really curious to get your guys
thoughts on ron dale moore the wide
receiver out of purdue
dude is super explosive but has a lot of
injury baggage so i'm curious how you
weigh all that and where you think he'll
ultimately end up coming off the board
thanks
rondelle moore connor yeah i love it
it's a tough one and he might be the
fourth guy on the dinner list when you
look at it
at lefko he gets you know he gets there
to purdue as a freshman and just lights
the world on fire he almost
single-handedly beat
ohio state so when you look at how
special he is
great athlete uh for uh he's not small
he's just short he's built really like
steve smith where he'll run
through you and this is what they do
they manufacture touches to him to get
up field so
a lot of action in the slot a lot of
screens
a lot of plays after the catch with the
ball in his hand so for rondale moore to
me
i know there's been injuries the last
two years i know we haven't gotten to
see the sample size that we hope to
but i watch the freshman year tape and
go i know i'm drafting this guy to be a
slot only but he's
special in the slot and that's okay so
top of round two for me for rondale
moore who is just
really a phenomenal another electric
kind of player that can change the game
at any moment and you just gotta figure
out what those injuries were was it
fluky
i think it was a little bit more of a
fluke and this guy's gonna have a really
good nfl career
maybe it's because of pierre garcon i
love wide receivers that are built
like running backs uh i you know there's
guys i think in the past that haven't
worked out like the bruce ellington's of
the world that
they've had solid careers but there's
those other guys that
when you watch a college offense need to
get the ball in their hands it's
exciting to watch
now it's time for us to talk about the
most electric
wide receivers there are a bunch but you
have circled
five five that are going to really
kind of whether it's over their pro days
catch people's attention with their 40
times
or people like me when you see their
highlights for the first time you go
who is that here is your list jalen
waddle
from alabama jalen darden from north
texas anthony schwartz lachaim
from auburn dwayne eskridge from western
michigan
and i want to start here 2-2 at well
which immediately i'm in love because of
his first
name but i know that sometimes when
you're electric
you're not the most sturdy i hear you
have some buzz on tutu at well what are
you hearing about his size connor
i'm fascinated by 2-2 atwell because we
know that he has nfl talent we know that
he has nfl speed he's obviously on this
list for a reason he's going to
absolutely fly and when you watch the
film
that's what he does he just gets over
the top and wins and that one was a
little bit too easy even though he's
begging for the ball wide open in the
end zone
but what i'm watching left go throughout
this draft process is
you know somebody told me that 2-2
atwell weighs 155 pounds right now
there are not a lot of players in the
nfl that are under a hundred and seventy
pounds
everybody's getting so caught up with
devante smith's weight
but they're forgetting tutu atwell who
there our people think could have been
coming into this year a top 50 pick
because of his
speed and people are going well is he
the next hollywood brown type of player
just a really really small guy
that benefits from the new rules in the
nfl that protect wide receivers a little
bit
but in my days of doing this left go you
don't run into a lot of a hundred and a
sub
160 evaluation so for 2-2 atwell
he's got to run in the four threes and
it's just tough to take hits at the next
level at that weight so
it's going to be interesting what he
does as his pro day
what he weighs in at and can he get that
number
up but i think it'll be under 160 pounds
let's say the weight is around there
let's say the speed though isn't the
four
threes who is a comp because we never
see guys at this weight
and what would be a right round for him
to go if that weight
is that low i mean the closest one i can
get for you is jakeem grant right when
jakeem grant came into the league
he's five six 161 so that's the closest
size one and
they're electric i mean look at it catch
and go nobody's catching up to me he's
special in that regard so
i think when you look at it we're not
gonna use the hollywood brown one as
much because he's not that
level of prospect but jakeem grant would
be the only guy i could think of here
let go but all these teams want these
vertical threats that
they don't have to represent number one
or number two targets you can put them
in empty sets whether you have five wide
receivers on the field even four wide
receivers on the field
and you want to just run four verts you
want to get your offense going
vertically
atwell absolutely has a place in the
league especially this modern offense
i mean we've seen one of the best teams
in the nfl use guys like this over and
over again in the kansas city chiefs
they just want somebody that can run by
everyone where
you're not worried about him getting
tackled because the only time he gets
the ball is when he's in the end zone
let's go quick with jalen waddle just
because we did talk about him at length
last week
you said this might be the closest we've
seen since tyreek hill waddle out of
alabama
oh i mean just insane the sub 4 3 speed
and it's a different kind of speed when
it's on the field and you could see it
early in his career as a kick returner
but then when he got a focal role in
this alabama offense
he's beating double teams and it's just
catching though
it's not i need to catch the ball and
then worry about getting up field and
overthinking it's
catch the ball and go all in one motion
where it's hard for anybody
to get a hand on him and a lot of the
mac jones highlights you're gonna see
it's just jaylen waddle wide open so
when i look at an electric player
he's someone that quite frankly as you
saw just there
you're not doing one-on-one coverage
you're not putting a corner on an
island against jalen waddle you can't do
it you're writing your own death wish if
you do that so from
day one he's polished enough as a wide
receiver to draw bracket coverage
and when teams sit off of him play off
coverage he can kill you underneath
because like i said let go that catch
and run
is as good as it gets in this class
and the oreo saying waddle wide receiver
one conor last week said not a bad prop
bet to put some money on
cr4w saying i hope waddle falls to my
cardinals
if the cardinals take a wide receiver i
think that they're going to have to have
a talk with their gm because there's
other parts of their team that needs
help
aj green de'andre hawkins larry
fitzgerald christian kirk
they don't need another wide receiver
right now cr4w but it would be really
cool
connor let's go to the guy that you've
been talking to me about for a month
jalen darden out of north texas
who does he remind you of give me the
full breakdown
yeah i think when you look at darden
number one coming out of north texas
he's someone in the last two years he's
really taken off and
it's just been great to watch because
he's smaller five nine one seventy four
but i compared him to a familiar face
from last year's class left go darnell
mooney who
really shined from the bears and you're
going to see it here with the highlights
in the slot and winning across the
middle of the field
nobody really runs with this guy
especially the level of competition he
faced where
look at how bad that ball is the
quarterback play was not good
but it didn't matter because like why
he's the waddle of a lower level
competition where
he's always so wide open i thought he
was one of the best separators
in this draft class in terms of the
route running in terms of the vertical
speed
there's a little bit of catch and go
again he's undersized and i did see
winds on the outside i want to make that
clear i don't like sitting there and
going
slot only slot only because everybody's
five nine 180 these days so
i saw wins on the outside i saw him
absolutely destroy
slot corners on the inside the only
question you're going to wonder from day
one can he get off press coverage at the
next level
but if you don't get your hands on him
he's going to run by you
what is a round approach like like
where's the perfect landing spot for
darden
i think you're looking at round four and
you're gonna look at those teams that
are still looking for some bargain
vertical threats right we talked about
it with the chargers
i think the chargers are somebody that
have a really great thing going with the
offensive line editions they've made
we know how good justin herbert was last
year we know they already have talent at
pass catchers but you let one out the
door right in hunter henry who's a
totally different type of player
now you're looking more of a vertical
offense and if they don't want to spend
a premium pick because
we talked about jalen waddle with the
giants and the chargers last week
well maybe the chargers say hey we got
other things to worry about right now we
did lose some guys in free agency
so we're gonna wait i look at jalen
darden and go listen
you probably get taken in round four and
it's the darnell mooney situation all
over again there's a role for him
right away at the next level because of
the speed because of the deep ball
tracking and because nobody's gonna rely
on him to be a number one
number two or number three from day one
uh speaking of sleepers the next guy on
your list was
dwayne eskridge out of western michigan
which has had a history in the past
of putting some interesting wide
receivers into the nfl
so who does eskridge remind you of
connor and and what do i need to learn
about this guy as i'm picking your brain
well he reminds me of someone that just
found a new home and that's john brown
smokey brown and you're noticing all
these speed comps they can't all be
tyree kill guys so this is the john
brown comp for me with eskridge
he used to play corner then they moved
him to wide receiver and then they
probably said what were we ever thinking
because every time this guy catches the
ball
it's electric you're seeing a theme here
with eskridge but what impressed me the
most with him was
at his size of five nine 190 he will
compete for the ball he will get
physical he will get feisty with corners
he will fight you in coverage it's not
just all catch and run
not just plays in space it's that i
don't care that i'm short
not necessarily small but sure i will
make a play for the jump ball
and let go there's been rumors of him
being timed already at 4-3-3
so it's going to be very interesting to
see what he runs in the spring
he's had some injuries in the past he
came back healthy and really lit the mac
on fire if you watch some football on
tuesdays or wednesdays this year even
you betters out there that's the only
reason
you had the mac on you would notice
dwayne estridge every single week
so you've already listed a few teams
that need speed at wide receiver
how deep is it in the nfl and do you see
eskridge around the same
lane as darden in that round three round
four
one of these teams that wants a vertical
threat like the chargers
i think we're looking in the third round
for eskridge lefko and the reason i say
that is he had the benefit of going to
the senior bowl where everybody goes
well you lit up the mac
we've seen plenty of guys do that we
don't care then you go to the senior
bowl
there was some good defensive backs
there some guys that will be drafted in
the top 60 of this draft
nobody covered them nobody ran with
dwyane estridge and i know it's really
really hard
for any defensive back in one on ones or
even seven on sevens all those drills
it doesn't matter there was nobody that
can cover this guy at the senior bowl
where all the scouts and evaluators are
sitting there
they remember how excited they get
because they haven't gotten those
opportunities much this year with covid
protocols
and they're looking around going sure
he's a little bit older of a prospect
he's had a windy road with injuries and
position
changes but we know this is going to
translate right away so
i don't think dwayne estridge makes it
to day three
last one anthony schwartz
i'm so excited to see what this guy
looks like because in my head
not what i expected him to look like
okay wide receiver out of auburn
uh-huh uh get give me or excuse me is it
aubrey yeah what do you think of this
kid give me the full breakdown is it
auburn is it syracuse what am i seeing
here
yeah so when you look at it he's at
auburn and i think that
you know he's not as polished as the
other guys yet right
he he's an interesting case because as a
track guy
we're talking about somebody that had
rumors of having olympic
level speed right and i noticed pro day
just ran an unofficial 4-2-6
but you're looking at olympic level
speed so he had to make a decision at
some point let's go but football is what
he
loves and i don't think he's very
polished as a wide receiver yet i see
separating i see route running
with eskridge darden waddle all of those
guys that we talked about i think with
schwartz it's a little bit of
middle of the field and the vertical
game the speed is there
but will the rest come together now i
will say this for him there's a little
meat left on the table because i don't
think bone nyx was very good throwing
the ball down the field so
i think with schwartz is he going to be
one of those guys that was a little bit
you know
underwhelming at times in the sec and
maybe wasn't as featured as much and not
that looks seth williams way the other
wide receiver that's draftable from
auburn this year
in short and intermediate areas of the
field i think an nfl team might go we
can put that speed to work
we know there's more to work with here
he's a day three player right now
but these guys will always always be not
overdrafted but a little bit
you know overvalued in a sense because
of how well they run speed kills at the
next level
schwartz has probably more of it than
anyone
very interesting uh okay i have to do
one thing conor because i'm paying
attention to the comments in the app and
i want everyone in the app to know
this is the last time i'm doing this
jcane1214
commented about 94 times in a row
if this happens again i will ignore you
or
i will have my friends over at the brf
block you because i'm trying to talk to
more people but this is the one time i'm
doing it jk
1214 asking who would be the best player
for the patriots to pick up at 15 in the
draft we talked about the patriots
earlier
but what is the dream scenario for the
patriots jay kane
i do not like you right now but i'm
doing this for the last time connor
hey we gotta help him out he's
persistent at best and you gotta give a
little respect to that so when you look
at the patriots i think the exciting
thing that i talked about earlier was
go up and get a quarterback and from a
system fit
trey lance is the one that excites me
for them the most right
but i think if you're sitting at 15
you're accepting the fact that you're
not getting a quarterback and then i
start to look at
cornerback for them and i know there's
been a lot of rumors around stefan
gilmore of late and a lot of
you know obviously this is a secondary
that's gotten older over the years they
did give a second round tender to jc
jackson who
is a fine player for them there's no
doubt about that but i think for new
england
at 15. they're a team that will always
beef up their cornerback group
but we'll see if they make an aggressive
play for a quarterback
i actually really like that app comment
question that came up let's throw that
back
up there from jason tatum fan zero uh
and it asked
connor and lefko what is your naggie
harris cump
well thank you jason tatum fano because
this is one of my favorite blender comps
that we get to do
in this year's draft where we got two
guys for you know one player comparison
here
it's steven jackson if you remember his
heyday with the rams left go
my goodness and
matt forte matt forte the pass catching
ability
there just aren't a lot of six foot two
230 pound run
your college is on point right now lefko
you remember all of these guys so
there's not a lot of six foot two 230
pound runners that can do this you see
that outside and then cut it back
inside and go and hey these are sec
defenders and no one's gonna run with me
and if you try i'm gonna stiff-arm you
we've seen the hurdle
we've seen the spin move we've seen the
stiff arm and we've seen the ability
there's the b button right there it's
filthy from naji harris the full skill
set the full package
all three downs never take him off the
field so i love the comp question
because he's somebody that
you just don't get a lot of these guys
you definitely don't get one every year
you don't get one every other year you
get one maybe every three years and with
naji harris
i just see so much steven jackson in his
game one of my favorite players to watch
growing up
he definitely has the stephen jackson
stiff arm and the matt forte
kind of stiff back when he runs a very
vertical runner
uh how is he at catching the ball and at
the same point
what's the dream landing spot for him
because i i want to compare him to
travis edtienne
but i want to finish up naji first so
catching the ball and the dream landing
spot for him
tremendous patch pass catcher not
somebody that needed to be used
just as dump offs but also somebody that
can go up and win the ball against
linebackers because
he's faster than all of them so he
usually has a step on them but he's just
as big as a lot of linebackers in
today's game and you see the contact
balance there
i mean it's just really tremendous with
naji harris and the landing spot for me
is the miami dolphins said the hurdle is
just ridiculous the miami dolphins are a
team
that they know they need to help out
their guy tua they've made some
additions already this offseason i know
they signed mascura so they're trying to
beef up that offensive line
i know you know a lot of people are
hesitant when talking about taking a
running back early
but the dolphins have a lot of extra
draft capital again this year
where naji is the perfect fit for them
maybe later on in the first round maybe
at the top of the second round
that's the landing spot for him he comes
in and he's a three down every
every kind of down player for them and
has the familiarity with the quarterback
already as well
um in terms of travis etienne i have
been hearing about this guy
for two three years how does he compare
tanaji harris
stylistically and overall as a prospect
well in the same mold they can both run
through you they both have that contact
balance but in a different kind of way
he's a home run hitter lefko you see it
if you give him any kind of space to go
he'll take it and he's gone and i think
that's what's special he's not as
complete as a player in the passing game
as naji where
you see the pass protection or the jump
ball ability but he does
have some skill as a pass catcher catch
and run kind of player because of that
raw speed
and i also think the vision is there
north south kind of ability he can also
fit in an outside zone scheme
so with etn he excites you because
listen he put on some weight
before he ran at his pro day he got up
to 215 and ran a 4-4 when he's playing
at 205
210 he runs in the four or threes and
just not a lot of people can keep up
with him
really polished at setting up defenders
in the open field so
i think he's a little bit more lightning
to naji harris's thunder
gotcha so he is more deandre swift from
last year than anything where
where would travis etienne have the best
career if he were to be drafted and do
you see it end of the first round
second round what do you see there the
easy answer is the 49ers i think it's
tailor-made for him to come
in and get those and now they bring back
trent williams so you have an absolute
beast to run behind and
you know that would be pick 43 which a
lot of people think he won't make it
there
but how many running backs do we see
fall over the years left go nothing
surprises you in that mold anymore
he really reminds me of cj 2k and i know
he's got a little bit more contact
balance
but he's somebody that is just the burst
is so phenomenal that
if you're not smart with your
containment at the first level of the
field
and you give him any kind of alley he's
gonna beat you and i think the niners
are so
good at calling the run game setting up
angles and he's somebody that if you
give those angles too
he'll beat you every time so etn to the
niners at pick number 43 would be my
dream spot for both
sides last year i remember all the mocks
had
ceh jonathan taylor deandre swift
some mocks had all three going in the
first round
we ended up getting clyde edwards
e-layer last pick in the first round and
then it was almost a mad dash
to go get jonathan taylor at the top of
the second de'andre swift
uh etn naji harris is it those two and
then a gap
and then what would you set the over
under for running backs in the first
round this year
so i think the wild card guy is javonte
williams from unc
who is a tremendous player in his own
right i compared him a little bit to
chris carson considering how
powerful of a runner he is but i think
he's got a little more juice and a
little bit more
wiggle and people love his character
they think he's somebody that can come
in and be
that leader which isn't always common at
that position so i think when you look
at javonte williams
a dark horse guy for rb1 but i think
this is naji harris's show right here
and lefko
i think we're gonna see 0.5 is the over
under
we're wondering if we get one in the
first round this year
i mean look at what running backs are
getting paid on the market right now
even aaron jones who's one of the best
running backs in the league
essentially when you crunch the numbers
kind of gets that two-year
20 million you know two franchise tags
kind of deal
is what the extension looks like the
value of running back is just
lost in today's nfl but these are
special prospects that
i think they go in the top 45 i just
wonder if anyone can sneak in the top 32
with how good this offensive line class
we're gonna see a run on them
we're gonna see five quarterbacks go in
the first round we're gonna see a run on
corners
we always see pass rushers even if it's
not a great pass rush class
a couple will go at the end of round one
i'm sitting there going
when do the running backs go i think
that conversation starts on night number
two
it is always interesting the positional
versatility the only argument that i
have about taking the running back early
whether it's the first or second round
is
you know the heart of a running back's
career is in that first four or five
years
so if you're really gonna wait for a guy
on that second contract you may not get
the best years of his career and then
after that
the nfl teams adjust let's go back to
the app here got a question from
roots rusi ph i'm gonna go rue
uh why isn't kenneth gainwell getting
more hype is there something i'm missing
connor well russy we just became best
friends because i don't get it either i
look at kenny gainwell and
i think the answer that you're probably
looking for is simply he didn't play
this year
and teams for whatever reason or hype
train forever at reason
it doesn't exist right now and i also
think this is a guy that maybe the nfl
wants to hide a little bit i think he
goes in the second round
he has reps in the slot he has reps in
the backfield he's an inside runner he's
an outside runner
he can make you miss he's very very
active in passport he's got great hands
he's probably the best pass catching
threat out of the running backs
in this entire draft so i don't think
you're missing anything
i think maybe the media hype which we're
guilty of at times might be
you know a problem of that but the nfl
is not sleeping on this guy i think he's
a top 75 pick
all the way and for those dynasty or
even the regular fantasy players
he will be a much much hotter name come
may
june july the kenny gainewell high
memphis they just churn out running
backs like no other
i was going to say he sounds like the
antonio gibson of this year's draft
class is he at that level or is gibson a
better overall running back at the
position
i think you value him i actually value
him a little higher that i thought
antonio gibson was a guy that was a
little bit more raw because of the
different positions he played and
obviously worked out just fine
but gainwell's the real deal lefko this
is a player that he played
quarterback in high school and then he
didn't play this year so when you're
looking at the running back wear and
tear
it doesn't exist and if you want to see
him have a great game
he ran very well against penn state
there's a specific play in passport
where he
almost knocks out micah parsons who's
going to be a top 10 pick at linebacker
so
gainwell is tough he's a three down
player
he's scheme diverse he has it all
i look at it across the board that he
you know he'll be valued more highly
than any of these really good memphis
running backs we've had in recent years
just got some breaking news the chargers
replaced hunter henry with
jared cook to a one-year deal six
million dollar contract so
they do get a tight end over the middle
solid blocker
big possession tight end uh kind of
wasn't as explosive in the last few
years with the saints but
it's hard to tell who was great with the
saints because so many people touched
the ball there
whether it was sanders or camara or cook
or thomas
you couldn't really get a track record
there it is time to move on to
cornerbacks connor and we have a comment
to help us take it there
it is from straight ahead are you sold
on patrick certain ii horn or
farley at 10. so he's really asking
is there a real top 10 corner in this
draft he says
i just don't see it i want a cornerback
that screams elite
at 10. so connor the real question here
is
do you find these players to be elite
and top 10 worthy
well i don't have them in my top ten to
answer the questions so straight ahead
you know he's sitting there as a cowboys
fan going is this a reach
a positional need reach right and i
would agree with you i like caleb farley
i like patrick certain
two totally different and jc horn let's
go through him real quick right
caleb farley compared him to marshawn
lattimore dynamic athlete didn't play
this year some injury concerns
about phenomenal athleticism phenomenal
ball skills patrick certain
your typical press corner i compare him
to xavier rhodes and he's not
that kind of speedy athlete he's more
technically sound
jc horn compared him to a keeb to leap
he just wants to play press coverage and
stay in your hip pocket all day
and talk his talk after the play and i
absolutely love that
go watch the auburn game he frustrated
seth williams and bo nicks all day
they and those are really you know lofty
comparisons those are good comparisons
but those are their ceiling comps and i
look at those players i have questions
about all of them
farley the injuries are not playing and
a little raw certain
you know obviously the deep speed jc
horn how much will they let him get away
with that play style at the next level
they are very ticky tacky with all the
calls so
if you're a cowboys fan at 10 there's
going to be better players on the board
those are good cornerback prospects
those are first round caliber cornerback
prospects
but they are not top ten picks to me
where i'd sit there and go
is kyle pitts there i'd like to take him
did one of the offensive linemen fall we
know we've been injured at that spot
over the years even though you signed
tyneseki
as your you know your swing offensive
tackle you can do a little better as
much as he's a solid
player so i totally hear you out and i
have my concerns there everybody's doing
it they're going cowboy's corner at ten
cowboys corner at ten
well if you're really that sure of it
can you trade back maybe get somebody to
come up for the last quarterback
available
get more picks and then take your corner
back at 15 or 19.
listening to you talk about the two
names at the bottom of the screen caleb
farley and patrick certain the second
it sounds like certain is the polished
guy it would make sense with his dad
being a pro bowler in the nfl himself
and farley is the explosive one so take
me through
i want to go through farley first give
me the breakdown
explain the comp a little bit more and
where would you like to see this guy go
yeah i think for farley all the tools
are there lefko if you need to do a
checklist of traits purely in the draft
you see it right there a little jam and
then run down the field he's not even
playing the ball but he's so fast and
long
that it doesn't matter great arm length
great height great deep speed
willing to come downhill and play the
run not as good as certain we'll get to
that in a minute
you could see him come break under the
ball it's really
all there it's just that there's not an
overwhelming amount of experience he's
somebody that
is a little raw in coverage as we saw
that the first play he's not playing the
ball he's just using athleticism it's
hard to get away with that at the next
level so
i think there's a longer transition
period for farley but the cop to
marshawn latimer is
that size speed all those traits when
they come together
you have a true number one shutdown
corner and that's what he projects at so
there's more risk
now when you get to patrick certain it's
a little different because i think the
floor is higher
but the ceiling is also capped he's
somebody that is phenomenal coming
downhill and playing in run support
literally no you see him right there off
the ball just reading the quarterback's
eyes and basically catching a punt
but the long arms there to go up and get
it so you like the arm lane
you're probably going to see him come
down here and read the run which he does
perfectly over and over again
there is no physical limitations with
him he loves playing alabama football
he'll throw that body weight around
he'll get his hands on you and he'll
time the ball so i think with certain
the only question for me is how is he
gonna look if he's asked to play in a
scheme
where he has to run the deep third is he
gonna be asked to play cover three
and really run with guys down the field
i don't think that really suits him i
think he's somebody that
you like him getting your hands on you
know hands on players at the line of
scrimmage slowing them down
using that arm length and physicality as
his advantage so
very different players can both be
number one corners at the next level
but not perfect players and i think they
get billed as that sometimes
who do you have higher i have farley
higher by
no i've certain higher by one spot
wow both good db schools too the only
concern i think with nick saban
dbs is they seem to kind of hit their
peak beforehand
uh you mentioned his limitations uh
whether it's deep and all that
i'm curious where where would you love
to see on draft day
you go adam a plus the scheme they run
at this team is perfect for certain
oh that's a great question lefko i think
you're looking at somebody like denver
even though that's early
but i think he can fit in there and
really really make an impact right away
i think when you go down the board we
saw minnesota just sign patrick peterson
so
i wonder how active they actually would
be in the cornerback market but before
that signing happened i look at
minnesota and go
you know i compare them to xavier road
so it's kind of the layup of a landing
spot we know what kind of cornerbacks
they like at that franchise and then if
he really really starts to slide
you know miami's taking corners over the
year washington's invested heavily
you're going to get down to probably the
indianapolis and tennessees of the world
tennessee just moved on from midori
jackson who
i thought was really good when helping
and man covered was gone from almost her
entire secondary
yeah so i think you're looking at
tennessee sitting there they're hoping
one of these guys falls and i think both
of them can play there there's no
problem with that i just think i really
like certain's fit in tennessee with his
play style
just kind of looking over the teams in
the draft the other names that kind of
come up that i know are going to need a
cornerback arizona just lost patrick
peterson their secondary's kind of been
hit or miss these last few years
the raiders have been trying to draft a
cornerback i don't know
you know all their their first round
picks have not really panned out as well
as they would have liked
and then you mentioned tennessee at 22
and cleveland at 26 is looking for a
secondary depth but
it sounds like you value these players
closer to 10 that you do at 20.
yeah i think so i think the position
matters right we're always going to talk
about how important getting cornerbacks
are especially cornerbacks
that are a little bit different guys
that we saw farley the deep speed's
phenomenal i think he's somebody that
when
all of the traits develop you're looking
at an island corner somebody that you
can have trail receivers and follow them
and shadow them and say
we trust you on this guy we're not going
to give you a lot of help over the top i
think that's what excites me
about him and then with certain not a
lot of rookie corners come in ready to
go and give you
true starting reps we saw jeff akuda
really struggle for the lions last year
cj henderson up and down i know he had a
really nice start to the season kind of
cooled off in the middle
it's not an easy position to play so i
look at certain and go
he's got a lot of things going for him
or he can come in and give you that
press coverage ability right away not a
liability as a run defender
sees everything really well in front of
him it's a good corner class and there's
going to be a serious run on corners in
the top 40 left go
not just these top two guys but i think
there's five that we could easily see go
in the top 40.
yeah the only other t it's interesting
now that i look about it look at it
15 16 17 patriots cardinals raiders
i could see all those teams wanting a
corner especially because
we don't know bill belichick 1 loves to
draft nick saban players
and we also don't know what's going to
happen with some of the corners already
on the roster
because we've heard a lot of trade
rumors so that should be interesting
we do is there anything you want to
comment before we get to rapid fire q a
here oh i just want to give a shout out
to greg newsome on this show i know we
we
showed him at the most electric to top
you know at the top of the show
sub 4 4 speed perfect and he's different
from the other guys i want to make that
clear if you're looking for an off
coverage corner with great instincts
that just sees
everything in front of him really fluid
great
hips light feet just tough we know
coming out of northwestern that that's
somebody you know who's going to be well
coached up
i love greg newsome in this draft and i
think when you're talking about his
draft
you know maybe floor the jets at 34
somebody he's gonna
fit into that cover three scheme with
salah like a glove
if the cowboys did trade out a 10 we
know they have dan
quinn there i think that's a really
really nice fit if they traded far back
newsom is the guy that no one's talking
about right now
that much outside of the draft community
and he's someone that
we could be talking about him round one
off the board left go
danny noonan i will be answering your
question at the end of the rapid fire q
a and to kick off our rapid fire q a
let's go to 408
for our last video comment of the show
take it away
connor my man i am a big fan of
that pass rushers peyton turner and um
ade ogendeji in like kind of round three
round four range
who are some of your favorites in that
spot and do you prefer athletes
or are you the kind of guy who who wants
more technique in production when you're
trapped in that
spot yeah
it's a fun one from forno right there
let's start with payton turner from
houston because you get your first
glimpse in when you watch zach wilson
against houston
uh he looks like a basketball player out
there left like a small foe or just
long arms long body really really
athletic has enough speed to contain the
outside run
and the pass rush traits are just
starting to click so payton turner is
kind of that fun round
three guy that has all the traits to
turn into something special he really
does i just think that
you know he's a little raw of course as
a pass rusher i don't think he's raw as
a run defender i think you could drop
him back at coverage at times that
versatility
is really really good and then when you
look at ade from notre dame
he's a big edge setter right a little
different probably going to play around
270
6'5 big strong
can hold that point of attack so two
very very different guys
in terms of one is your raw hey let's
get see what we can get out of him as
this
you know swiss army knife kind of edge
and then when you look at ade
i think he'll just do the old school
dirty work up front you gotta respect
that
where do you stand though on the uh
you know i want a polished good hand
technique guy
versus here's a raw power denial
hunter type that if it hits it hits big
where do you stand and does it depend on
the round
it depends on the round and it depends
on what's coachable and what's not right
some guys just naturally have a great
get off the snap and then they don't
know what to do right i think when i
watch someone in this draft like patrick
jones
from pit you can see how explosive he is
off the snap but there's no pass
pass rush plan right now you watch him
against notre dame
and he has reps against two draftable
players liam eichenberg and then
hainesey on the right side
who's the team captain those guys are
very polished technicians so i think
when you're looking at it left go it
just depends
well i know he has a good get off i know
he's a good athlete you're looking for
players like that
but can we teach him to counter inside
does he have the bend to turn the corner
is he somebody that's twitchy those are
all the things that you wonder here and
you're gonna see teams always value
traits look at jason elway from penn
state
no sax this year and being talked about
as a potential round one pick because at
250 pounds he might run in the four
freeze it's crazy things like that so
it's all traits left go it's all based
how you value it and you just have to
weigh
everything on a case-by-case basis
it's time for rapid fire put those
questions on the bottom the screen crew
brett
canvasser let's see what you guys got
for us first
rapid fire question is if holiday signs
with the giants
who should they then target at 11 hc41
conor what do you think
they lost kevin zeitler to free you know
they had to move on from him for salary
implication reasons i look at rashawn
slater there somebody that can play
pretty much anywhere you ask of him on
the offensive line this offensive line
they did draft two tackles last year
they gave him a lot of reps last year it
still needs work it needs a lot of work
you're committing to daniel jones give
him a chance i don't think kyle pitts is
there at 11. if you go get gallaudet
you got some help at wide receiver but
you gotta help in the trenches more
next one rapid fire keep it moving keep
it moving do you think aziz
oh jalari or jason away i don't know if
i got those names right apologize to
those humans nailed they picked 26 for
the
nice at pick 26 for the browns is a good
fit opposite miles garrett
i love it and let's start with oh jalari
ogilari would be the one that's the fit
for me i i don't want to wait and try to
develop a guy like oh way
during miles garrett's prime i want
somebody that can come in and give me
even if it looks like a little bit of a
one-trick pony
it's a it's a dang good trick is what we
like to call it oh jalari
first step best outside speed rusher in
the country this year
loved what i saw finished plays strip
sacks really good off the ball not a lot
of liability against the runner
knocked out pulling guards ogilari at 26
would be a steal for cleveland
they did lose larry ogen joby to the
bengals this week so they do need some
more horses on that d-line in cleveland
st flynn asks can you give me three dark
horse
long snapper prospects i
i can't i didn't do long snappers yet
and i'll try to put them in you want
punter or kicker specialist we have a
couple of those somewhere in this dock
but
i apologize i'll take i'll take the best
picture in the draft
who's the best i have two in here
and they're nothing special hold on one
sec lefko this is not good
rapid fire content it's gonna be uh
jose boragalus from miami transfer from
fiu had a really good season he won the
groza award
i think he's somebody that is super
accurate this year big leg
long of 57. if you can hit from 57 in
college you could probably do it in the
nfl so borgalas would be the top kicker
he's no rodrigo blankenship and
underscore the ear the oreo
chances indy takes an edge rusher round
one indy picking at 21.
yeah it should be high right you look at
it no more justin houston we're assuming
and even if something came
you know to terms there i think it's
time to really get a little younger
uh indy is an old school team they're
going to build with pass rushers and
corners and an offensive line
they've done a really good job at
offensive line can they keep building an
edge rusher they've taken their swings
over the years
hasn't really worked out in the draft
route so when you look at 21
jalen phillips azizo giulari
there's a lot of names across the board
i know we've talked about away a lot
quitty pay is the athlete kind of like
away so but pity
quiddy pay is a little bit more of a you
know productive player this year so
there's a handful of guys that fit the
cults in round one and i like what ant's
thinking i think we should be looking at
edge for them early
they need to get it deforest buckner was
great they need more speed on the edge
the bread man 10 connor and lefko thank
you for having the show so much fun to
watch
who do you think oh what do you think
your 40-yard dash
would be connor i'll let you go first
i don't know it's a good ques can we can
we run sub fives let's go i think that's
what the world wants to know i'll say
no i like this question i don't think i
can either
this question is so good at some point
of draft crash course i will record a
video we can roll into the show of me
running a 40
and the watcher the the viewers can get
their stopwatches out
i will not be running said video i would
put mine at a five
five uh i've never been i'm more quick
than fast i'm more
twitchy than long speed connor
people don't realize how fast anything
sub 5 is
it is absurd and then that's why when
people get hung up over 4
4 4 3 you're crazy
if people think they can run faster than
offensive lineman what i would love to
see is them getting a 10 yard head start
on an offensive lineman
and getting chased because the fear that
would overcome that would be crazy we
have three minutes left
i want to get one more question in here
something that i was dealing with before
the draft show from danny newton
he says hey flims hey flimsy mf
are here why clown our fan base the jets
and put us all in one boat when talking
to jamal adams
clown question bro uh connor and i have
talked about this
um if you watch the full episode what
happens when you put out clips is
i was saying to jamal you went from lsu
to the nfl
where everybody loved you and then when
once you got traded
they changed on you and i was not just
saying that the jets were flimsy
i'm saying that all fans are flimsy you
are going to see it this week
when juju starts making tick tocks for
your jets if he ends up signing there
you're going to see steelers fans
flipping on them real quick
i watched my fan base the philadelphia
eagles
flip on like a 12 year old kid because
now
he is a carson wentz fan as jerry
seinfeld says
fans root for laundry they don't root
for athletes and so what happens
is danny when you're talking to an
athlete
you need to understand what it does to
their mentals
when millions of people go from adoring
them
to absolutely hating them something
happens just like you probably went from
liking me to thinking that i should go
bury my head in the sand
you have to understand that it impacts
people that was the question
jets fans the reason that i love you is
you've always reminded me of eagles fans
you're east coast you're green and white
and you've always felt
like the giants get more attention than
you did so
i apologize that it came off that way
but also
understand that i ain't never gonna stop
and i ain't never gonna quit
and i appreciate you for watching connor
as a jets fan was that okay did i sum
that up all right
it was beautiful i am asking uh the
peace treaty amongst jets fans and adam
lefkow
adam is on our side so the peace treaty
is enacted from now on that'll be the
end of that
thank you connor that was great a draft
crash crash course
thank you to everybody watching in the
br app hopefully i got to read some of
your questions it's been a party in
there and that was really fun
uh as always you can watch us on
gridiron twitter be our youtube if
you're listening on the left go show
podcast great
the next theme for next week we already
got people asking for kyle trask
is going to be the quarterbacks we are
going to do
the top quarterbacks you're hearing
about all the time and we are going to
do the other quarterbacks but
every nfl draft will be remembered by
the quarterbacks selected in them
submit your questions as videos the
three that got mentioned today and
played on the show
you will be getting a br gridiron hoodie
and hope to give out more hoodies
post those videos in the nfl draft
community we will play them live on the
show
thank you for watching connor pleasure
as always man thanks dude
i love it man it's been a blast and next
week is going to be awesome
[Music]
so
[Music]
you